ก็
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนอ่า
แยกปี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียมโอเคโอเคนะครับ
กลับมาเจอกับเทียนตี้เจอกับน้องเรียมนะ
ครับเย้ในช่องคอมพรี ansible ไทยโอเคจ้า
ฮ่าๆแล้วผมนะวันนี้วันนี้เรามาเจอกันอีก
แล้วนะมาเรียนภาษาไทยกันใช่ไหมครับอ่ะใช่
เอามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันวันนี้วันนี้วันอะไร
ครับวันนี้
วันนี้วันอังคารมาซ้ายแล้ววันนี้วัน
อังคารโอเควันนี้วันอังคารใช่ไหมวัน
อังคารวันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันอังคาร
ที่ 1 วันนี้วันที่ 1 นะมหาวันที่ 1 แก่
วันอังคารที่ 1
แล้วเดือนนี้ครับเดือนนี้เดือนนี้เป็น
เดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนนี้เดือนกุมภาพันธ์ 5 เดือน 4
กุมภาพันธ์วันที่ 1 วันที่ 1 กุมภาพันธ์
เป็นวันแรกของเดือนใช่ไหมวันแรกของเดือน
อะวันที่ 1  5 ใช่ครับ 5 เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
แล้วปีนี้ปีคศอะไรครับ
ปีนี้คศ
2000  22  5  2012 โอเคแล้วปีพศอะไรครับ
มีผช
2565  2566  5 ใช่แล้วครับหาเคแล้วปีนี้
ปีอ่า
พ.ต.กศ.
2522 ใช่ไหมนี่ปีนี้ใช่ค่ะ 22 ปีหน้าปี
หน้าปี 2462 อะไรครับ
ปีหน้าคอ 2010
4  23  5  2023 เป็นปีหน้าใช่ไหมปีหน้า
ไม่ใช่ปีนี้ปีนี้ 2,000
22r ใช่ครับเองแล้วปีที่แล้วปีที่แล้วปี
ที่แล้วปีกคศอะไรครับมีที่แล้วปีค.ศ
2005  21 ค่ะ 5 ปีคศ 2010  21  5 ปีที่
แล้วใช่ไหมครับ x ปีนี้พ.ต.ปีนี้พ.ต.
2565 ใช่ไหมใช่ 5 ปีหน้าปีหน้าปี
พตพฒนาพศ
2560  6  5
2566 โอเคครับอ้าแล้วตอนนี้ตอนนี้ที่ก็
มาเรียนกันนี่เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันตอนกี่
โมงครับตอนนี้ตอนนี้
11:00 น 11 โมง 11 โมง
15 นาที 5 เป็นตอนเช้าหรือตอนกลางคืน
ครับ
ตอนเช้าค่ะอ้าวขึ้นเช้าใช่ไหมก็แสดงว่า
เป็น r  a  m ใช่ไหมอ่ะตอนเช้า 11:00  15
นาทีนะอ่าโอเคครับ
R
แล้วอีกอีก
2 ชั่วโมงอีก 2 ชั่วโมง
จะเป็นเวลาเท่าไหร่ครับ
อีก 2  2 ชั่วโมงชาติใช่ก็จะเป็นเวลา
13:00 นา 2 เป็นตรงนี้ใช่ไหม 5
13:15 นใช่ไหม 13:00 น 13:00 ก็ต้องเป็น
หาแฟนพี่เอ็มแล้วใช่ไหมอ่ะโอเคบายโมง 15
นาทีอีกสองชั่วโมงชั่วโมงได้ครับอีก 2
ชั่วโมงฮะโอเค
อาวันนี้วันนี้วันนี้เรามีอะไรมาคุยกับ
นักเรียนครับ
เฮียอะไรมาคุยกันวันนี้เตรียมดูดูในทีวี
ครับ
เด็กผู้หญิงเตรียมก็เป็นผู้หญิงขอครับพี่
เป็นผู้ชายได้เพียงที่เป็นเพียงเห็น
เด็กผู้หญิง
ขายกระเป๋าขอไปเอาเรียกดูทีวีเห็นเด็กผู้
หญิงในทีวีใช่ไหมเด็กผู้หญิงในทีวีทำไมนะ
ครับสะพายสะพายกระเป๋า
สะพายกระเป๋าเข้
ใช่ค่ะก็เหมือนในรูปนี้
นี่คือกระเป๋า
กระเป๋ากระเป๋าเปล่า
ตา
รอ 5 เฮียตี้รอนะเพียงเขียนหานักเรียน
กำลังใจเขียนอาจเค
มีกระเป๋าอยู่ตรงนี้มี
มีกระเป๋าแล้วมีโอ้มีในกระเป๋ามีของเยอะ
เลยมีของเยอะในกระเป๋าเนื้อโอเค
ครับได้ไหมครับนักเรียนเขียนได้ไหมครับ
อ้าไหนโรงเรียนเขียนได้ไหมครับไหนลอง
เขียน
ได้ค่ะได้แล้วครับเสียง ka อ่อนอยู่ในรูป
นี้มีกระเป๋าใช่ไหมครับว้าวขายกระเป๋ามี
ของเยอะเลย
ให้ของเมตรของเยอะมากๆครับ
วันนี้เครียดตี้กับเหลี่ยมจะมาคุยกัน
เรื่อง
มีอะไรในกระเป๋าอ๋อ
อ้าวเฮียตีก็อยากรู้อยากรู้ว่าในกระเป๋า
มีอะไรบ้างมีอะไรบ้างในกระเป๋ามี 5 มีค่ะ
หน้าเรามาดูกันครับว่ามีอะไรในกระเป๋า
บ้าง
ไปครับ
ก็อ้าอันนี้อยู่ในกระเป๋าหรอครับอันนี้
อยู่ในกระเป๋าอยู่ในกระเป๋าเมื่อกี้ใช่
ไหมแล้วอันนี้คืออะไรครับ
อันนี้คือกระเป๋าดินสอ
กระเป๋าดินสอ
ที่อยู่ในกระเป๋า
ในกระเป๋าโอเคใช่หาอยู่ในกระเป๋ากระเป๋า
ดินสอผ้าอยู่ในกระเป๋า k  k  ok ครับอ่า
แล้วเทียบที่มีกระเป๋าดินสอไหมคะเปียตี
ไม่มีกระเป๋าดินสอดินสอเพียงตี้ไม่ใส่
กระเป๋าดินสอพี่
ใส่กล่องเยอะแยะเลยไม่ใส่กระเป๋า
ไม่ใส่กระเป๋าใช่เก่ามาโอเคอ่าในกระเป๋า
ของน้องเวียร์มีมีดินสอใช่ไหมมีดินสอใช่
ค่ะดิดินสอใส่กระเป๋าเราเรียกกระเป๋า
ดินสอ
ดินสอค่ะโอเค
แล้วก็มีออกแบบที่เป็นแบบนี้ค่ะไหนครับ
อ๋ออ๋ออันนี้ไม่ใช่กระเป๋าอันนี้เป็นอะไร
ครับ
อันนี้เรียกว่า
กล่องดินสอเป็นกลองหน้ากล่องดินสอเป็น
กล่องที่เอาดินสอเอาดินสอใส่ลงไปใส่ลงไป
ในกล่องใช่ไหมอ่าไอเรียกใส่กล่องให้ศ.
โอเคครับหน้ามีกล่องดินสอต๋อยรียน tpt
เห็นมีดินสอหน้ามียางลบด้วยใช่ไหมครับ
นั่นใช่ยางลบไหมใช่ยางลบไหมให้ค่ะมิอัน
นี้ยางลบอย่าง - อ๋อมีดินสอมียางลบนะครับ
อยู่ในกล่องดินสอด้วยโอเคอ่ะไงต่ออย่าง
เดียวใส่ยางโลกในกล่องด้วยโอเคครับให้ค่ะ
แล้วก็จะมีเทียบที่เห็นข้างๆกล่องดินสอ
ไหมค่ะค่ะข้างๆกล่องดินสอเพียงตีเห็นมี
ปากกาอยู่มีปากกาใช่ปากกาไหมปากกา
ปากกา
หน้าครับใส่ดินสอด้วยกล่องดินสอใส่ยางลบ
ด้วยกล้องนิ่ม 2 ใส่ปากกาได้ด้วย 5 ใส่
ปากกาด้วยโอเค
ลดกล่องดินสอก็อยู่ในกระเป๋าเอากล่อง
ดินสออยู่ในกระเป๋า 5 ในกระเป๋ามีกระเป๋า
ดินสอใช่ไหมเมื่อกี้มีกล่องดินสอโอเคอ่ะ
มีอะไรในกระเป๋าอีกครับน้องเรียมมีอะไร
อีกเหรอมี
ดินสอกดอ๋อและก็ก็ดินสอกดกด
ok ใช้กฎใช่มั้ยกดแล้วก็จะเขียนได้เนอะ
กดตรงไหนครับกดตรงไหน
กดตรงนี้ค่ะหน้าเพื่อตีไม่มีดินสอกดโอเค
อ่ากดตรงด้านท้ายใช่ไหมไปอ่านด้านท้ายจะ
มีที่พักเองอ่าโอเคครับ
ตี้ปไม่มีดินสอกดใช่ครับเพื่อนพี่
ไม่มีดินสอกด
ไม่มีดินต่อกดไม่มีเลยที่มี
ขี้
แล้วก็มี
ได้ดินสอ
ดินสอกดต้องมีไส้ด้วยใช่ไหมกินสองหน้ามี
ไส้ที่เรากดออกมาเวลากดฝากกดกดไส้ไส้
ดินสอก็จะออกมาใช่ไหมครับ
ไส้ดินสอไส้ดินสอครับ
ก็จะใส่ใส่ไส้ดินสอในดินสอกดใช้คำไส้
ดินสอ 2 อันเล็กๆใช่ไหมอันเล็กๆค่ะเล็กๆ
เล็กหน้า
มันจะมีไส้ดินสอที่เป็น 2d
อ๋อ
ใช่
ที่แบบสีดำๆนะคะสีดำ
สองพี่น้องโอเคสีดำ
เพี้ยนที่เคยเห็นดินสอมิสอส่วนใหญ่ที่พี่
อาร์ตี้เห็นจะเป็นดินสอ hb
ใช้ภาษาอันนี้ก็สีดำเหมือนกัน
HD ใช่ไหม
182  dc2b ดำกว่าดำมากกว่าใช่ไหมครับ
มากๆนะเป็น 2
bkk2 ดีกับ HD โอเคไส้ดินสอมีไส้ดินสอ
อยู่ในกระเป๋าแล้วในกระเป๋ายังมีอะไรครับ
มีนี่ฮะ
อ้า
ดินสอเรียกอะไรคะหาเพื่อนตีเรียกดินสอ
ดินสอได้ครับดินสอ
ใช่ค่ะเราเรียกสั้นๆว่าดินสอได้หรือว่า
เรียกถ้าเกิดถามว่าดิน 2 อันไหนดินสอกดก็
ไม่ชอบอ๋อ
ถ้าดินสอกดต้องกดได้แต่ถ้าดินสออันนี้กด
ไม่ได้ก็กดไม่ได้เรียกดินสอแทงครับดินสอ
ถ้ากดทับได้บางคนก็เรียกดินสอไม้หมอเรียก
ดินสอไม้อ๋อก็ทำไมเรียกดินสอไม้ครับเพราะ
ว่าตรงนี้ทำมาจากต้นไม้
ทำมาจากไม้ไม้ก็ทำมาจากต้นไม้
ก็เลยเรียกดินต่อไม้ใช่ครับถ้ามีดินสอมา
ให้เราก็มีดิน 2 กดเที่ยงนะโอเค
แล้วก็มีน่ารักน่ามีอะไรอีกครับพี่คิดว่า
ชื่ออะไรหน้านี้พี่คิดว่าน่าจะเป็นปากกา
ปากกาใช่ไหมฮะปากกาพี่มีเยอะมีฝากตายเอ้อ
นี่ปากกาปากกาปากกา
ดูสิมักกาหลายสีเลยนะฮะปากกาครับอันนี้
คือปากกาสีอะไรคะปากกาเพตี้คิดว่าประการ
นี้น่าจะเป็นสีดำปากกาสีดำนะจ๊ะหากคนไทย
เรียกสั้นๆเรียกปากกาดำ
ใช่ค่ะปากกาดำๆ
ใช่แล้วถ้าอันนี้ล่ะคะอันไหนครับอ้าอัน
นี้ก็ต้องเป็นปากกาแดง
เพชรตี้ก็มีปากกาแดงมีปากกาแดงเพราะมันสี
แดงเวลาเขียนเวลาเขียนออกมาก็จะเป็นสีแดง
เขียนเอามาก็เป็นสีแดงอ่ะปากกาแดงใช้คำ
แล้วถ้าอันนี้ล่ะคะ
อันนี้หรออันนี้ไม้บรรทัดอ่ะอย่า
ลืมสลับโอเคอันนี้ปากกาเหมือนกันปากกา
เหมือนกันแต่ว่าไม่ใช่สีแดงแล้วอันนี้นี้
เป็นปากกาน้ำเงินมีแผนที่ก็มีปากกา
น้ำเงินประกายน้ำเงินเวลาเขียนเวลาเขียน
ก็จะเป็นสีน้ำเงิน
อ่าเป็นปากกาน้ำเงินเขต
แล้วอันนี้ล่ะคะ
ไหมครับอ๋อ
อันนี้เรียกคนไทยเรียกไม้บรรทัด
ไม้บรรทัดใช้ครับ
บ๊ายมันคัดเตรียมใช้วางวาง
หน้านี่นี่ก็มีไหมบัญชัอ้าใช่ครับเอาไว้
ขีดเส้นเส้นขีดเส้น
ตายแบบนี้ถ้าอย่างนี้พี่จะลองขีดเส้นใช้
มาทับจะขีดเส้นด้ายตรงลงไปเนี่ย
ลงไหม e  mail คิดว่าตรงหากแต่ถ้าเบี้ยตี
ไม่ใช้ไม้บรรทัดนะมันก็จะเป็นแบบนี้
อันนี้ไม่ใช้ไม้บรรทัดไม่ตรงถ้าใช้ไม้
บรรทัดลง
ใช่ไหมมันทักวางแล้วนะขี่ขี่ๆ
ขีดเอาไว้ว่าขีดเส้นเพราะว่านี่เป็นเส้น
เส้นอ่าใช้ไม้บรรทัดขีดเส้น
ขีดแทงแต่พี่จะตีเห็นเห็นบนไม้บรรทัดบน
ไม้บรรทัดมีตัวเลขอยู่ด้วยมีตัวเลขแล้วก็
มีขีดขีดเล็กๆ
ใช่ค่ะมีตัวเลข 1  2  3  4  5
แล้วก็มีขีดเล็กๆขับถ้ามันคืออะไรครับ
อันนี้เราเอาไว้ผมขอเอาไว้วัดอ่ะเอาไว้
วัดความยาวว่ายาวเท่าไหร่ใช่ไหมยาว 1 เซน
2  cm  3  cm น้อ
เฮ้ยมีดินสอ
ดินสอว่างโอเคหรอกเข้าหวาน
ดินสอ
ยาวกี่เซนคะพี่คิดว่าอันนี้ดินสอน่าจะยาว
อ่า 4  cm ใช่ไหมครับ 4  cm  cm จนใคร
เรียกเซนติเมตรแต่ว่า cm คนในเรียกสั้นๆ
เรียกว่า 4  cm น่าได้ครับ 4 เส้นสี
เซนติเมตรเราเรารู้เพราะว่าเราเอาไม้
บรรทัดไม้บรรทัดมาวัดวัดเขตค
อีก
เเล้วฮ่ามีอะไรครับอีกสักอย่างนึงมีอะไร
อีกสักอย่างนึงไว้ในกระเป๋าอ๋ออ่อนนี้เอง
นี่อะไรครับอะไรนะอะไรวงเวียน
วงเวียนโอเคเป็นวงเวียนวงเวียนวงเวียนใช้
ทำอะไรครับ
วงเวียนใช้
ขีดเส้นวงกลมขอขีดเส้นที่เป็นวงกบถ้าเรา
ใช้มือกี่แบบนี้
มันไม่กลมใช่ไหมไม่โกรธลงๆต้องใช้วงเวียน
ใช่ไหมครับพี่ตีไม่มีวงเวียน
ตีวงเวียนเลวอ้านไม่กลมเอ้อนะอ๋ออ๋อใช้วง
วาดวงกลม K  ka
หือแล้วก็มีอันนี้ค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้อาบ
มีอะไรครับเอาพี่พริกลมกำลังวาดวงกลมยาม
ว่างวงกลมให้มันกลมโอเคอ่ะมีอะไรใน
กระเป๋าอีกครับมีหนังสือใช่ไหม
หนังสือหนังสือหรือโอเคเป็นหนัง
เยอะมากๆซื้อเยอะเลยอยู่ในกระเป๋าโอเค
หน้าค่ะแล้วก็มีเอ่อ
อ้อนี้อะไรครับ
อันนี้ใช่ไหมอ่าใช่
อะไรครับดูน่ารักแปลกๆ
กบรับกบเหลาดิ
ครบเขาดินสอโอเคเราดินสอใส่เข้าไปใส่เข้า
ไปในกบใช่ไหมแล้วก็หมูหมุนหมุนอ้าก็จะ
เหลาดินสอให้นึงสอนสามารถเขียนได้
เป็นกล่องเหล่าก็ขอ
จบแล้วดินสอคนไทยก็จะเรียกว่าซั่นว่ากบ
แสดงใช่ไหมใช่ครับกบ
พี่คะเรียมขอกบ
เหลาดินสอหน่อยค่ะขอก็อปล่ะสอนตัวตีมั้ย
มีกบขอเพียงจีไม่มีดินสอด้วยก็เลยแล้วอีก
อบไปเขา
[เพลง]
แล้วก็แม่
มีอะไรอีกไหมมีอะไรอีกครับเวลาเราจะหมด
ล่ะคะพี่แถวเวลาเราหมดแล้วเดี๋ยวอ้าอัน
สุดท้ายอันนี้อะไรครับมีอะไรครับวันนี้
เลขออกเครื่องคิดเลขเคเครื่องคิดเลขอะมี
ตัวเลขอยู่ตรงนั้นเราเวลาเราคิดเราอยากจะ
รู้ว่า 1  +  200  +  300  +  400 เราก็
กดในเครื่องคิดเลขใช่ไหมกดกลัวเลขขอกดตรง
ตัวเลขก็ไม่ต้องคิด Valley ไม่ต้องคิดเอง
ให้เครื่องไอ้เครื่องคิด
ได้เราก็เลยเรียกว่าเครื่องคลิป
เลขโอเคอะเครื่องคิดเลขโอเคครับ
ทั้งหมดนี้ก็มีในกระเป๋าในกระเป๋านัก
เรียนเลย
โอเคมีเครื่องคิดเลขใช่ไหมมีอะไรอีกครับ
มีกบเออใช่คือปากกา
มีไม้บรรทัดอ่ะอ่านักเรียนอ่าไร่มีอะไร
บ้างแต่ดูซิกระเป๋า Lyn  2 อันนี้กระเป๋า
ดินสออ๋ออ๋อครับผมอะมีอะไรอีกครับลอง
ดินสอ
กล่องดินสอ
เครื่องคิดเลขเครื่องคิดเลขโอเค
ไส้ดินสอไม้ดินสอไส้ดินสอกดเลยนะครับโอเค
ไม่ดี 2 กดแล้วก็มีดินสอดินสอไม้ใช่มั้ย
ฮะธรรมจักรให้ทำมาจากต้นไม้เรียกปากกา
ปากกานี้ปักกาดำโอเคอ่าจะใช่ค่ะ
ประกาอากาแดง the  way  they
ไม้
ไม้บรรทัดได้ครับ
ประการน้ำเงินโอเค
ๆ
อ้า
วงเวียน
วงเวียนครับอาหารสุดท้ายอ้าหนังอื่นๆ
ทั้งหมดก็อยู่ในเยอะเอากระเป๋าที่ใส่ของ
เยอะมากๆๆครับๆ
โอเควันนี้เราหมดเวลาแล้วในกระเป๋าของโรง
เรียนวันนี้มีของเยอะเลยนะครับนักเรียน
ได้เรียนรู้สิ่งของต่างๆหลายอย่างเลยครับ
วันนี้อาหารใช่ก็ถ้ายังงงอยู่ยังสงสัยนะ
ครับกลับไปดูใหม่อีกรอบนึงได้จะได้จำได้
ว่าของอันไหนเรียกว่าอะไรนะครับแล้ว
เดี๋ยวคราวหน้ากลับมาเจอกับพี่ตีกับมาเจอ
กับน้องเรียมใหม่ในช่องคอมพิวเตอร์ครับ
ไทยนะครับ
ใช่คนนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนค่ะค่ายครับหน้า
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เรียนตัวดีครับน้องเรียมบ๊าย
บายสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนใหม่เว้ยเออ
ม.ค